we're getting a look at newly released
video evidence used to convict Patrick
Frazee of killing his fiancee Kelsey
Bharath in Colorado it was just obtained
by 48 hours and this video shows Frazee
secret girlfriend at the murder scene
showing investigators how she cleaned up
the mess after the bloody crime Frazee
was convicted this week and will spend
his life in prison nikki batise has been
investigating the story from the very
start
this is Krystal Lee wearing a Colorado
Bureau of Investigation jacket and hat
showing investigators how she cleaned up
a bloody crime scene Lee was the
prosecution's star witness in the case
against Patrick freezy it was
Thanksgiving Day 2018 when Kelsie was
last seen in public hours later she was
dead prosecutors say Frazee beat her to
death with a baseball bat in her own
home while their baby girl was in the
next room Lee Frazee secret girlfriend
says she had been at her home in Idaho
when Frazee called telling her you got a
mess to clean up Lee says she drove 12
hours to do it I had been instructed to
try to wash things this ATM surveillance
image shows the container Frazee used to
transport Kelsey's body
we brought the tote here we unloaded the
tote
okay lead took investigators to Frazee's
ranch and showed them where Frazee
transporte Kelsie's body and burned it
[Applause]
and this is where the burn occurred Lee
says she tossed some of the bloody items
she took from the home on the fire
including baby Kelly's stuffed animals
and a Bible was whose Bible I don't
think we would have known what happened
to Kelsie without crystal Lee prosecutor
Jennifer vmon says Lee helped them put
the pieces of the crime together
freezies plan backfired when crystal
decided to cooperate with police do you
think if patrick had an involved crystal
he would have gotten away with Kelsey's
murder yes he very well could have
gotten away with that but he wanted
crystal Lee depended on Frazee was
sentenced to life in prison but Lee is
facing a maximum of up to just three
years for evidence tampering it was say
prosecutors a deal with the devil and
Nicky batiste joins us at the tell you
more you hear about that story the more
gruesome it is how many stuffed animals
what people don't understand is why did
she agree to clean up this crime scene
can you give us any insight into her
thinking crystal a complicated
relationship with Patrick she says she
loved him but that he also threatened
her and her family and she feared him in
this 48 hours we have even more
never-before-seen videos of her
surveillance of Patrick the last image
of Kelsie ever that's not been seen a
juror saw and I'll tell you it's all
really unbelievable to piece together
I know prosecutors said that they made a
deal with the devil she got a maximum of
three years a lot of people are saying
that ain't right she actually faces up
to three years her next court appearance
is December 2nd so we'll wait to see
what her final s yes all right Nikki
thank you very much and you can see
Nikki's full report justice for Kelsie
Bharath tomorrow night at 10:00 9:00
central right here on CBS